one through three mike
give me something before we go to break
one through one
all right
you already know like whenever somebody
just puts a video on the screen that
features people in a shopping thing
you're like this isn't gonna go well
well this is a walmart
milk protest they're standing in front
of the milk so people can't get to it
oh good
[Applause]
[Music]
they're wearing cow masks they're
wearing cow masks and
making dogs noises which is weird
[Applause]
[Music]
so they're holding signs two memory
counts once dragging a cow away from
another cow
you'd laugh right i would be [ __ ]
dying like i i that's the thing i would
be [ __ ] hysterical laughing about
in the store people would be like
serious
like you can't and it's like you can't
get i can't get in trouble flying
[Applause]
[Music]
hey by the way you know you know that
the milk
doesn't kill the cow no it does not
no it does not kill the cow in fact you
know if you're if you're a milk producer
killing your cattle is actually
counterproductive correct because you
need them for the milk for milk for milk
yeah because
it's not like it's not a one-off they
don't have just like
one one amount of milk in their titties
and their titties are draining to kill
the cow
imagine how expensive milk would be
kidnapping wait are people
in the cows royce i mean look i'm not
gonna say no because maybe some
are but i don't think all of them and
also they're not really
kidnapping the cows right like there's
no more
i don't think we're out there like
without capturing
wildlife with a [ __ ] lasso yeah right
i'm pretty sure we have facilities where
they breed correct
the cow okay just making sure
what is this
that was actually might have been better
than laughing
that actually might have been better
than laughing oh man i love this woman
now is this
she's so like she's so truly like
what what in the world did i walk into
what is this as you can see this is a
demonstration of what happens
and mother calls on dairy farms
yeah cool i'm just trying to get to the
ice cream because the ben and jerry's is
bogo so can you like move over
that's the thing though because it only
takes one like one
like really annoyed tired black guy
that's been at work all day he just
wants his ice cream that could get them
out of the way very quickly
yeah look man hey look no disrespect
nothing man i ain't trying to [ __ ] on
anything but you need to get the [ __ ]
out of my way right now because i need
to get some [ __ ] milk like you need
to get the [ __ ] out of my way right now
and that's all the time they'd go
okay okay and it would just be awkward
because they have to stop and then he
opens up the thing and he's like
and then he looks at the door hey baby
you want two percent or do you want to
okay the whole milk thank god okay
thank you
so the one of the the some of the cows
on the floor with
our kids they're having their kids do
this
your children should be taken from you
um
stop eating babies wait what how do we
how did we graduate this is an epstein
protest
how well thank god no no honestly people
want to just start going out and
protesting epstein and saying stop
eating babies
in frozen food sections across the
country i would not discourage that
behavior
but this is not what about in front of
places of worship
like unitarian church like we were
talking about earlier
so anyway they're saying what is the
baby's thing i'm not
don't do it do not do it do not do it so
this old lady's trying to get milk okay
here we go here we go here we go
oh no this oh this old lady just wants
her milk
and they say white people don't have any
culture although they do
listen white people might think milk is
spicy but when they want their milk they
gotta get their milk
right so look look she's gonna try to go
they're not moving for dude at that
point walmart should kick
right
i mean as long as they're still giving
enough room to open the door
do you know how much how on purpose that
how much more i would open it though
oh no i know well i got to get to the
one in the back
the expiration date the fresher milk's
in the back it's not bent
archer back and bend over and push them
okay god damn it she's a hero
that
i want to hug this old woman hug the old
lady you don't want to hug her
i hate hugging people no but i don't
want to have to some people in america
you just go i gotta give you a hug lady
it's my milk it might seem like a
worthless small victory but it's a
victory
these people need to be ridiculed and
that is that was how you do it
somebody really needs to edit music like
we
are the champions
look at that basket of capitalism she's
wheeling around so you know what that's
a good call i want to live dude
look at the potato chips can i come live
with you
oh yeah see she had her son with him too
by the way i know he looks young
but that kid looks like one of those
kids that will fight people
right then yeah he just looks like one
of those little skater kids from texas
that would probably start [ __ ]
fighting people in a heartbeat so that's
why she went in over saying i got my son
with me i'm pretty sure
my son will start bitch-slapping
protesters
it's too late so jesus
lord before you laugh and mock us
excuse me you you probably should have
opened with that one
cause now i feel like almost everybody's
already laughed at you
so
um imagine taking your [ __ ]
where's his dad well
i think that his where's his new dad is
right next to him i think that
his new what that is his new dad
you're right you're right it's his new
dad that he calls mark
oh [ __ ] uncle bark
that's what it is i mean that's his
wife's son
all right guys not someone's saying
prison come on shut up
they already did they did that bit on
calm town but it's hilarious they were
talking about adam's like
chick getting knocked up by a black guy
and then him just being such a [ __ ] that
he would live with it
hey hey yo dad hey yo dad let me ask you
something
hey yo dad let's go to movies yo let's
go dad
but that's like i'm just picturing the
come town bit right now
uh yo dad hey yo dad how you yo why come
on
you want me to play like sports and [ __ ]
then how am i supposed to do it without
drinking milk hey dad
it's it's we ain't we ran out of milk
dad it's it's
it's like uh me myself i remember you
myself and irene
yeah jim carrey's kid were all these
black big black kids
wasn't my name is earl didn't he have a
black kid dude i don't remember yeah he
had a half black baby it was there was
you know hey yo jet hey yo dad i like
milk though yo for real you also real
[ __ ]
[Applause]
no darnell you're gonna put water on
your cereal like your people prefer now
hand me another mayonnaise sandwich hey
yo dad what do you mean people like us
right yeah like us like us
hey yo pops you said if i helped you and
you're dead
you said if i helped you protest against
uh the corporate dairy fascists then you
would buy me like
nba [ __ ] 2k19 we're gonna go to the
toy section right
hey yo dad
like i can't see my baby anytime once
the street lights are out at night
come on man that's mean hey
how come every time you at work mom
always be having friends over hey yo dad
who's mom's friend darnell
how come i saw jordan's at the front
door but you don't wear jordan's
literally the kid's name is darnell and
mom also has a friend
named darnell that comes over during the
day hey dad he got the same names
weird no look i fully admit that the
adam jr bit was a come down bit but
that's just
all this reminds me of right now is a
duh yeah
you'll pop
but what i don't understand is like okay
you're allowed to protest outside of a
business right
on a sidewalk i mean you are inside of a
business
why is walmart taking so long to kick
these people out
because they're walmart employees rice
even the manager's not going to kick
them out though
it's walmart they're probably called the
police but this could be right
look dude there's a walmart every
[ __ ] five feet in america so this
that may not be this this may not be
like the walmarts we're used to where
there's a cut there's cops
stationed there yeah this isn't the
[ __ ] uh fowler avenue walmart in your
busch gardens that
right there's like an actual swat team
detachment
inside of a mobile command yeah yeah
just in case
you know [ __ ] pops off at the walmart
this might be a white walmart
in which case they're like hi could you
send a sheriff that gets
sherry from walmart could you send a
sheriff's deputy down here
no it's not a thief actually you're not
going to believe this but
some man and his black stepson are
protesting in the milk section and we
need to get him out of there
that's right black stepson i know
it's a shame i know think of the parents
but anyway
i'll see you when you get yep exactly
thank you
that's how that phone call sounded
from their mother yes they do
when did orangutan milk come into the
[ __ ] mix
so you can see another lady walked up to
hear that so you can't go over there and
get milk
here uh it's kind of hard to get past
the girl standing in front of the door
people are still shot nobody cares
nobody cares yeah i love this i love
just this all this is is you
making a scene with your black step kid
yes that's all it is
right but there's no there's a point to
it this couldn't be
like if you told me that that guy was a
right winger
i'd believe you you think so like if you
told me that this was a
this was a larp and that was a
right-wing guy and he actually because
of how these kids come with him and
everything like it just
this guy's such a stereotype yeah it's
that's what it makes me think
like i could picture ellie werewolf
being like hey can i borrow you're going
to
need
i got to go to walmart for this thing
[Applause]
why are you taking black kids away from
their black dads i mean if you're
worried about cows
[Music]
look i don't care i know it's a come
down bit but i'm doing it one more time
hey yo dad why is everybody staring at
us yo dad
we gotta get up out of here dad the [ __ ]
po po is gonna come dad
i learned that i learned the term po-po
dad i learned it from mom's friend
darnell senior that comes over
when you were
wait your mom has a friend named darnell
senior and he doesn't have any kids
that's weird baked alaska's there
apparently
oh my god maybe it is him i mean
by the way you saw porcelain's baked
alaska documents coming out like friday
night
he's baked is ever evolving that could
be him that's why i'm actually like
right he's pro-trump again
he's also single again
that's what the rumor is i'll find out
[Music]
yeah find out from that dumb stupid
don't do that
what then i'm not going to find out
find out from that bpd all right come on
what's going on
that's not going to help me
it's not going to help me figure it out
now
great now i gotta be like hey what's up
you having fun
no here's the thing though i know this
is a true treat for you guys out there
people with borderline personality
disorder
you can treat them like total [ __ ] and
they they'll always
because they know their [ __ ] got it so
you can be a total dick to them and
they'll forgive you
it's the weird it's one of the only
upsides to borderline personality people
is
they're so narcissistic that you can be
horrible to them
but usually they're so obsessed with new
things about them that they forget all
about it